boris is dead number 10
5 and 4. is the prime minister's number
up in this wakefield community centre
it's 200 miles from westminster and
politics feels very far from the reality
of people's lives here as they interrupt
their bingo game to hear the
government's priorities for the coming
year there is just one thing on their
minds and they don't feel like
politicians get it
don't let the philip understand
just how hard it is for people
you know you've all the bills to pay
and then in between that you've got a
bit of a thought to pay for if you can't
thank you
the government says they are addressing
the cost of living crisis but people
here fear for the future
i think everybody's scared i think
everybody's really scared but we also
know that there's really not much we can
do right now nobody will be okay not
just our clients we're worried about our
employees as well
at the last general election boris
johnson won over places like wakefield
in west yorkshire and he'll need to hang
on to them if he wants to hang on to
power next time round but he won't have
to wait that long to find out what the
people of wakefield really think because
there's about to be a by-election here
so having heard today's queen's speech
are they prepared to give him a bit more
time or have they run out of patience
[Music]
for this community choir the government
is hitting the wrong note when it comes
to key areas like brexit
does anyone here vote for brexit
yes i did but we didn't have the full
information
do you regret your vote yes
very much so what about levelling up
yes important or no yes important
do you think it's going to happen
no
why not
the rich get richer and the poor get
poorer and they're not the only ones
that have lost faith bishop tony
robinson has spent 25 years serving this
community but believes today's political
leaders are failing this area at a
crucial moment
there have been times when you know
people have come to the fore and led the
country in a way that's got us out of
some crises
but at the moment i don't see that
happening no but i fear for the lies of
a lot of people in our communities
it is going to be a really tough time
over the next two or three years because
i think it's going to take that long to
get back to some sense of normality
on big political days the people of
wakefield often feel ignored but it
won't be long until they go to the polls
and westminster will be forced to hear
their voices those in power may not like
what they have to say liz bates sky news
in wakefield